you find a mountain and you start
climbing you spend your whole life
climbing it and you get say two-thirds
of the way and then you see the peak is
like way up there but you're two-thirds
of the way up you're still really high
up but not to go the rest of the way
you're gonna have to go back down to the
bottom and look for another path nobody
wants to do that people don't want to
start over yeah and it's the nature of
later in life that you just don't know
the time so it's very painful to go back
down and look for A New Path but that
may be the best thing to do and that's
why when you look at the greatest
artists uh and and creators they have
this ability to start over that nobody
else does like Elon will you know be
called an idiot and start over doing
something brand new that he supposedly
is not qualified for or when Madonna or
Paul Simon or YouTube come out the new
album their existing fans usually hate
it because they've adopted a completely
new style that they've learned somewhere
else and a lot of times they'll just
miss completely so you have to be
willing to be a fool and kind of have
that beginner's mind and go back to the
beginning to start over if you're not
doing that you're just getting older
nibby just made the point to me on the
side that inspiration is perishable
which is a very good point when you have
your inspiration do it right then and
there this happens to me a lot with my
tweet storms I've actually come up with
a whole bunch of additional tweets
starting besides the ones that are
already out there but sometimes it just
hesitate or I just pause and then it
just dies and what I've learned is if
I'm inspired to write a blog post or to
publish a tweet storm I should probably
do it right away otherwise it's not
gonna get out there I won't come back to
it so inspiration is a beautiful and
powerful thing and when you have it just
seize it so people talk about impatience
when do you know to be impatient when do
you know to be patient my glib tweet on
this was impatience with actions and
patience with the results and I think
that's actually a good philosophy for
Life anything you have to do just get it
done why wait you're not getting any
younger your life is slipping away you
don't want to spend it waiting in line
you don't want to spend it traveling
back and forth you don't want to spend
it doing things that you know ultimately
aren't part of your mission and when you
do them you want to do them as quickly
as you can while while you do them well
with your full attention but then you
just have to give up on the results you
have to be patient with the results
because you're dealing with complex
systems you're dealing with lots of
people it takes a long time for markets
to adopt products it takes time for
people to get comfortable working with
each other it takes time for great
products to emerge as you polish away
polish away polish away so impatience
with actions patients with results and
as nibby said inspiration is perishable
so when you have inspiration act on it
right then and there if you stop trying
to figure out how to do things the way
other people want you to do them then
you'll get to listen to that little
voice inside of your head that wants to
do things a certain way and then you get
to be you and no one in the world is
going to beat you at being you you're
never going to be as good at being me as
I am and I'm never going to be as good
at you being you as you are so certainly
listen absorb but don't try and emulate
it's a Fool's errand instead each person
is uniquely qualified at something they
have some specific knowledge capability
and desire that nobody else in the world
does this is purely from the
combinatorics of human DNA and
development and so and so your goal in
life is to find out the people who need
you the most to find out the business
that needs you the most find the project
and the art that needs you the most
because there's something out there just
for you but what you don't want to do is
be building checklists and decision
Frameworks built on what other people
are doing because you're never going to
be there you'll never be good at being
at somebody else the whole phrase is
what feels like play to you but looks
like work to others and all those words
are deliberately chosen like feels like
because it's your internal feeling like
play so it's fun but looks because the
outside person doesn't have the feel
like work to them and if it looks like
work to them then you can monetize it
and it can be useful so all four of
those pieces are important in that
sentence all of those criteria have to
be fulfilled for you to find something
that is a worthwhile Endeavor where
essentially it's your hobby but it's
everybody else's vocation it's your
avocation their vocation and that's how
I know no one can compete with me on it
because I'm just playing 16 hours a day
and if they want to compete with me and
they're going to work they're going to
lose because they're not gonna do it 16
hours a day seven days a week a happy
person wants ten thousand things a sick
person just wants one thing right so
it's your it's your unlimited desires
that are clouding your peace your
happiness have desires your biological
crazy sort of stands up and says I can
do something I I move I resist I live
but just be very careful of your desires
this is the oldest most right wisdom
desire is suffering that's what it means
right every desire you have is an access
where you will suffer so just don't
focus on more than one desire at a time
the universe is rigged in such a way
that if you just want one thing and you
focus on that you'll get it but
everything else you gotta let go
the reality is I don't actually read
that much compared to what people think
like the re I probably read one to two
hours a day
which and that puts me in the top
0.0001
uh I think that alone accounts for any
material success that I've had in my
life and the intelligence that I might
have because real people don't read an
hour a day real people I think read a
minute a day or less uh so making it an
actual habit is the most important thing
and how you make it a habit doesn't
matter it's very much like exercise or
working out do something every day it
almost doesn't matter what you do so the
people who are obsessing over like
should I be weight training or should I
be doing tennis or should I be doing
Pilates or should I be doing the high
intensity Training Method versus the
happy body versus whatever they're
missing the point the important thing is
to do something every day it doesn't
matter what it is so the same way I
would argue the important thing is to
read every day and it's not it doesn't
matter it almost doesn't matter what you
read because eventually you'll read
enough things and your interest will
lead you there that it will dramatically
improve your life so just like the best
workout for you is the one that you're
excited enough to do every day the same
way I would say the best books to read
are the ones that are books or blogs or
Twitter or whatever anything with ideas
and information and learning the best
ones to read are the ones that you're
excited about reading all the time I'm
actually an anti-social introvert
and I was just lost in the world of
words and ideas from an early age I
think some of it comes from the happy
circumstance that when I was young
nobody forced me on what to read I think
there's a tendency among parents and
teachers to say oh you should read this
but don't read that the reality is I
just read a lot that by today's
standards would be considered mental
junk food but eventually you just get to
like reading you run out of the junk
food and then you start eating the
healthy food right or your tastes kind
of graduate so I think to some extent
that's what happened with me because I
started from comic books and then run
from that into Mysteries and went from
that into fantasy you get into sci-fi
and then from if I admitted to science
and then mathematics and then philosophy
so it just kind of kept climbing up the
stack but I'm lucky that there was no
one around when I was seven years old or
16 years old saying oh you shouldn't
read that you should read this instead
now what I realized is that the biggest
mistake was memorization right because
when you're actually trying to live your
life in congruence with reality you you
want to have a deep understanding of
what you do and why you do it and so
it's much more important to know the
basics really well than is to know the
advanced knowing calculus wouldn't help
you today it doesn't help you in
business doesn't help you in most things
but knowing arithmetic really will help
you really whether it's at the Corner
Grocery Store counting change to
figuring out the value of your podcast
business to figuring out how to do the
probability math on you know some action
that you want to take so understanding
basic mathematics cold is way more
important than memorizing calculus
Concepts and the problem is and this is
true of I think all reasoning it's much
better to know the basics from the
ground up solid found Foundation of
understanding a steel frame of
understanding that is to just have a
scaffolding which is memorizing advanced
concepts this is why there are a lot of
people I'm sure that you listen to who
are really smart they use a lot of
jargon and you can't quite follow their
reasoning you don't know how they're
putting things together and you're this
deep down suspicion they don't even
really understand right so if you look
at the the most powerful thinkers
especially the ones where money or life
is on the line
they have to understand the basics
really really well Richard Feynman the
physicist was able to he had this piece
in one of his lectures where he takes
you from counting numbers on your hand
all the way to calculus in four pages of
text in the orally but written Downs
four pages of text and it's a complete
unbroken logical chain that takes you
through geometry trigonometry
precalculus analytic geometry graphs
everything all the way to calculus he
understood numbers at a core level he
didn't have to memorize anything when
you're memorizing it's an indication
that you don't understand you should be
able to rederive anything on the spot
and if you can't you don't know it
so do you apply that to things other
than mathematics you apply that to
everything everything
and the first thing if you're going to
make money is that you're not going to
get rich renting at your time there are
many reasons for that but the most basic
is just that your inputs are very
closely tied to your output in almost
any salary job even a one that's paying
a lot per hour like a lawyer or a doctor
you're still putting in the hours and
every hour you get paid so what that
means is when you're sleeping you're not
earning when you're retired you're not
earning when you're on vacation you're
not earning and you can't earn
non-linearly if you look at even doctors
who get rich like really rich it's
because they open a business they open
like a private practice and that private
practice builds a brand and that brand
attracts people or they build some kind
of a medical device or a procedure or a
process where they have intellectual
property so essentially you're working
for somebody else and that person is
taking on the risk and has the
accountability and the intellectual
property and the brand so they're just
not going to pay you enough they're
going to pay you the bare minimum that
they have to to get you to do the job
and that can be a high bare minimum but
it's still not going to be true wealth
where you're retired shared and then
finally you're not creating new things
for society you're just doing things
over and over and you're essentially
replaceable because you're now doing a
set role most set roles can be taught if
they can be taught like in a school then
eventually you'll be competing with
someone who's got more recent knowledge
who's been taught and is coming in to
replace you you're much more likely to
be doing a job that can be eventually
replaced by a robot or by an AI and it
doesn't have to be wholesale replaced
overnight it can be replaced a little
bit of a time and that eats into your
wealth creation and therefore your
earning capability so fundamentally your
inputs are matched to your outputs you
are replaceable and you're not being
creative I just don't think that that is
a way that you can truly make money so
the first thing you have to do is you
have to own a piece of a business you
need to have Equity either as an owner
an investor shareholder or a brand that
you're building that accrues to you to
gain your financial freedom
so this newest form of Leverage is where
all the new fortunes are made so all the
new billionaires the last generation
fortunes were made by Capital that was
the Warren buffets of the world but the
new generation fortunes Are All Made
through code or media Joe Rogan making
50 to 100 million bucks a year from his
podcasts PewDiePie I don't know how much
money he's rolling in but he's bigger
than the news right the fortnite players
of course Jeff Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg
and Larry Page and Sergey Brin and Bill
Gates and Steve Jobs that is all code
based leverage probably the most
interesting thing to keep in mind about
the new forms of Leverage is they are
permissionless they don't require
somebody else's permission for you to
use them or succeed for labor leverage
somebody has to decide to follow you for
Capital leverage somebody has to give
you money to invest or to turn into a
product but coding writing books
recording podcasts tweeting youtubing
these kinds of things these are
permissionless you don't need anyone's
permission to do them and that that's
why they're very egalitarian they're
great equalizers of Leverage
and it's really it's actually really
important to have empty space if you
don't have a day or two days a week in
your calendar where you're not always in
meetings and you're not always busy then
you're not going to be able to think
you're not going to have good ideas for
your business you're not going to have
good judgments so I also encourage
taking at least one day a week
preferably two because if you budget two
you'll end up with one uh a day a week
where you have nothing on your calendar
and you just have time to think
um it's only after you're bored that
you're gonna have the great ideas uh
it's never going to be when you're
stressed or busy or running around or
rushed so make the time
to me the real winners are the ones who
step out of the game entirely who don't
even play the game Who rise above it and
those are the people who have such
internal mental and self-control and
self-awareness that they need nothing
from anybody else so there are a couple
of these characters that I know in my
life
um some older gentlemen that I like to
kind of learn from and we mentioned our
polish friend earlier I would consider
him successful because he doesn't need
anything from anybody yeah he is at
peace he is at health and whether he
makes more money or less money or with
the next person over from him does
better or worse than him has no effect
on his mental state and bearing and
historically I would say that the
legendary Buddha or Krishna Morty Who
stuff that I like reading they are
successful quote unquote in the sense
that they step out of the game entirely
winning or losing does not matter to
them there's some line that I read
somewhere that all of man's troubles
arise uh because he cannot sit in a room
quietly by himself for a half an hour
right and if if you could literally just
sit if you could just sit for 30 minutes
and be happy you were successful uh and
I think that that is a that is a very
powerful place to be but very few of us
get there now let me leave you with some
words from Steve Jobs Warren Buffett and
Charlie Munger on some of these rules be
ready to start over Steve Jobs said I
didn't see it then but it turned out
that getting fired from Apple was the
best thing that could have ever happened
to me the heaviness of being successful
was replaced by the lightness of being a
beginner again less sure about
everything it freed me to enter one of
the most creative periods of my life
do what feels like play but looks like
work similar to this Steve Jobs said
don't be a career the enemy of most
dreams and intuitions and one of the
most dangerous and stifling Concepts
ever invented by humans is the career a
career is a concept for how one is
supposed to progress through stages
during the training four and practicing
of your working life there are some big
problems here first and foremost is a
notion that your work is different and
separate from the rest of your life if
you're passionate about your life and
your work this can't be so they will
become more or less one this is a much
better way to live one's life overcome
the need for external validation Warren
Buffett said would you rather be the
world's greatest lover but have everyone
think you're the world's worst lover or
would you rather be the world's worst
lover but have everyone think you're the
world's greatest lover your answer to
this question will tell you whether
you're doing things for the sake of
external valuation or for the sake of
your own driven passion fall in love
with reading Charlie Munger reads around
500 non-fiction books every year he said
the following in my whole life I have
known no wise people who didn't read all
the time none zero you would be amazed
at how much Warren reads and at how much
I read my children laugh at me they
think I'm a book with a couple of legs
sticking out Navarro vacant has also
said that it's not about educated versus
uneducated it's about likes to read and
doesn't like to read personally my main
three sources of learning are videos and
podcasts books and the book summary app
short form which I explained next show
from create super insightful study
guides from hundreds of non-fiction
books and it has helped me to discover
and learn ideas much faster the cost is
equivalent to the price of one book a
month and you can use my affiliate link
shortform.com picking nuggets to get a 5
day free trial and a 20 discount on the
annual subscription you can also find
the link in the description below